[Musik]
es ist einer der außergewöhnlichsten
Kriminalfälle die es in Deutschland je
gegeben hat der Bombenanschlag auf die
Fußballmannschaft von Borussia Dortmund
am 11 april 2017
natürlich ist das kein Routine voll ist
einer der spektakulären Fälle in meiner
polizeilichenkarriere was die Ermittler
am Ende auf die richtige Spur bringt das
hätten sie nie erwartet
wenn mich vorher jemand gefragt hätte ob
ich einen entsprechenden Anschlag für
Möglichkeiten hätte hätte ich gesagt
dass das wird nie passieren schon 10
Tage nach den Explosionen lösen Sie den
Fall und nehmen einen Täter fest der aus
Habgier Todesopfer in kaufnamen was der
Täter alles an Anstrengungen unternommen
hat das war für mich in der Gesamtschau
schon verblüffend
am Hotel larivé in Dortmund dort wo die
Bomben explodierten treffe ich die
Ermittler Martin grönert und Walter
Kämpfer den ZDF erzählen sie exklusiv
wie sie dem Attentäter das
handwerklichten der Bus ist mit einer
Geschwindigkeit von etwa 15 bis 20 km/h
hier durch die Straße gefahren und als
der Bus dann genau an dieser Stelle
gewesen ist hat der Täter dann die
Fernzündung betätigt und hat diese drei
Sprengsätze die er in der Hecke
platziert hatte zur Umsetzung gebracht
gehabt
Stahlbolzen fliegen durch die Luft einer
schlägt durch die Scheibe des Busses und
bricht dem Spanier Marc bartra den
Unterarm landet dann in der Kopfstütze
des leeren nachbarsitzes Spiele und
Betreuer schreien werfen sich auf den
Boden rufen den Busfahrer zu er soll
weiterfahren aus Angst Terroristen
könnten den stehenden Bus Stürmen der
Blick um die nächste Ecke und bleibt
stehen ein Polizist der auf einem
Motorrad vorne wegfährt er leidet ein
Knalltrauma alle anderen stehen unter
Schock
wir haben an den Fahrzeugen vor Ort
Splitter gesehen die teilweise die
Scheiben der Fahrzeuge durchschlagen
haben die teilweise das Karosserieblech
der
Fahrzeuge durchschlagen haben im
gegenüberliegenden Einfamilienhaus sind
auch
Splitter durch die Verglasung in einen
Wohnraum im ersten Obergeschoss
eingedrungen Peter Setzer war
Sprengstoffexperte beim
Bundeskriminalamt er hat rekonstruiert
wie die drei Sprengsätze zusammengebaut
wurden welche Materialien und
technischen Hilfsmittel der Täter
benutzt hat im Umkreis von mehreren
hundert Metern liegen mehr als 60 dieser
Bolzen von insgesamt 90 die der Täter
verwendet hat
die stadtbolzen waren also relativ
gleich später hat sich ja herausgestellt
dass er diese Teile selbst aus
Edelstahlstangen geschnitten hat
etwa in den Abmessungen so 74 75 mm lang
6 mm Durchmesser bei einem ca Gewicht
von 16 Gramm machte mir also schon den
Eindruck dass hier ein Täter oder Täter
am Tatort tätig waren die
entsprechend Erfahrung hatten im
Hersteller von springvorrichtungen aber
auch in der Taktik wie ich solche
springenvorrichtungen einsetzen
noch am Abend entdecken die Ermittler in
der Hecke und an einer Mauer drei
identische Bekennerschreiben es sind die
Spuren 1 2 und 3
[Musik]
im Namen Allahs des gnädigen des
barmherzigen 12 Ungläubige würden von
unseren gesegneten Brüder in Deutschland
getötet aber anscheinend scherst du dich
Merkel nicht um deinen kleinen dreckigen
Untertanen deine Tornados fliegen immer
noch über den Boden des Kalifats und
Muslime zu ermorden jedoch wir bleiben
standhaft durch die Gnade Allahs ab
sofort stehen alle Ungläubigen
Schauspieler Sänger Sportler und
sämtliche Prominente in Deutschland und
anderen Kreuzfahrer Nationen auf
Todesliste des islamischen Staates
die schreiben lassen zunächst auf einen
Anschlag des sogenannten islamischen
Staates is schließen doch die Ermittler
haben Zweifel es ging um die Art und
Weise wie die Sprache benutzt wurde es
ging um die Rechtfertigung der Tat die
nicht klassischen Bekennerschreiben
entsprochen hat wie wir sie aus anderen
Anschlägen kennen denn es wurden
Forderungen aufgestellt ungewöhnlich für
den is
Tornados aus Syrien abziehen
Rammstein Airbase muss geschlossen
werden wie ermitteln weiterhin in alle
Richtungen lautet deshalb die
Sprachregelung auf keinen Fall wollten
wir uns vorher irgendwo einschränken das
heißt wir sind im Bereich islamistischer
Terrorismus
Rechtsextremismus
eventuell bombenaffinitäter aber auch
Hooligan Fußball Gewaltszene haben in
alle Bereiche erstmal ermittelt
am Tag nach der Explosion entdeckt ein
Spaziergänger in einem nahegelegenen
Wald eine frische Brandstelle er
informiert die Polizei
Walter Kemper und Martin Gröner sind
sich zunächst unsicher hat dieser Brand
etwas mit dem Anschlag auf den Bus zu
tun man konnte sehen dass das eine
relativ frische Brandstelle ist und die
in Luftlinie 300 Meter zwei durch den
Wald entfernt war vom larivé und wir
glauben selten an Zufälle und deshalb
haben wir auch versucht näher zu
untersuchen was hat es ja für sich die
Ermittler finden in den verkohlten
Resten belgische und französische
lebensmitteldosen Sardinen und Thunfisch
beispielsweise außerdem verbrannte
technische Geräte eine Taschenlampe
Batterien und dieses Nachtsichtgerät
wir haben angenommen ob dort
möglicherweise einen Mittäter genächtigt
haben könnte ob man dort möglicherweise
die Vorbereitungen für die Tatausführung
getroffen hat da alles verbrannt war war
es sehr schwer im Bezug auf Spurensuche
Fingerabdrücke oder DNA-Spuren dort zu
gewinnen
später erschnüffeln Polizeihunde eine
Verbindung zwischen dem Hotel und der
Brandstelle im Wald die Hundeführer
haben den Einsatz in diesem Video
dokumentiert
wir konnten dann aber nachher dann
nachvollziehen dass der Täter diese Spur
bewusst gelegt hat um von sich
abzulenken um den Verdacht auf
möglicherweise belgische Terroristen
oder islamistische Terroristen aus
Belgien zu lenken so wird der Fall eine
Wendung nehmen in eine ganz andere
Richtung die die Ermittler nie für
möglich gehalten hätten
[Musik]
in einem Forum einer Tageszeitungen in
Österreich schreibt ein Nutzer unter dem
Namen Jerusalem irgendjemand hat gestern
große Mengen 60.000 Stück put
Optionsscheine auf die bvb-aktien in
Frankfurt gekauft und dies mit einem
niedrigen Basispreis und kurzer Laufzeit
großer Kursverlust gleich hoher gewinnen
diese Scheine wurden glaube ich noch nie
zuvor in Frankfurt gehandelt
wahrscheinlich nur ein Zufall
die Aktien von Borussia Dortmund können
an der Börse gehandelt werden wer auch
immer diese Put-Optionsscheine gekauft
hat er spekuliert auf einen Absturz der
Aktie fällt die Aktie steigen die
Optionsscheine auch bei den Dortmunder
Ermittlern wird der Forum Eintrag zum
Gesprächsthema so richtig ernst nimmt
ihn aber niemand
in der ersten Besprechung dann am
Donnerstagmorgen um 9 Uhr hatten wir
verschiedene Spuren und unter anderem
war diese Aktien
Spekulation der wir aber zu dem
Zeitpunkt jetzt noch nicht eine
Priorität zugeordnet haben also wir
haben uns gedacht das wäre ein starkes
Ding wir haben uns das zunächst erstmal
kaum vorstellen können doch wer ist der
Hinweisgeber hatte den richtigen Riecher
oder will er sich nur wichtig machen
wir fahren nach Bad Ischl im
Salzkammergut eine Stunde östlich von
Salzburg hier lebt Rudolf scheuchel 48
Jahre alt BVB-Fan ehemaliger Banker und
Börsenexperte wir als Österreicher zum
BVB-Fan wurde weiß er nicht mehr
wahrscheinlich waren es die Aktien zu
Hause hat er einen ganzen Raum in
schwarz gelb dekoriert hier guckt er mit
seinen Söhnen alle Spiele der Borussia
am Nachmittag vor der Explosion schaut
er sich den Kurs seiner eigenen
Optionsscheine die sogenannten Putz an
und macht eine Entdeckung
ich habe diese 60.000 Butz entdeckt und
war mir zu 100% die sicher dass diese
etwas mit dem Anschlag zu tun haben
müssen wieso diese Optionsscheine werden
Mal überhaupt nie gehandelt dann diese
Menge ein paar Stunden vorher und noch
dazu an der falschen Börse normalerweise
werden diese Optionsschein in Stuttgart
gehandelt die Umsätze habe ich aber in
Frankfurt gefunden das war so
ungewöhnlich für mich dass ich mal
gedacht habe dann musste das dahinter
stecken er ruft beim BVB an und wird
zunächst abgewiesen dann verweist er in
einer Mail auf den möglichen
Zusammenhang zwischen Anschlag und
Börsengeschäft
wäre der Anschlag gott behüte geglückt
hätte es einen enormen Gewinn gegeben ca
50-fach wie gesagt wahrscheinlich
vielleicht nur Zufall mit besten Grüßen
aus dem schwarz-gelben Rudolf scheuchel
wenn der Kurs sehr schnell deutlich
abstürzt bekommt viel Geld das ist wie
wenn ich eine Haushaltsversicherung aufs
Nachbarhaus abschließe und Sünde ist
dann selber bauen der Unbekannte zahlt
für die 60.000 Optionsscheine 26000 €
und wettet damit auf einen Absturz der
Aktie wäre der Kurs auf Null gefallen
hätte er 622
000 € Gewinn machen können doch soweit
kommt es nicht die Aktie fällt nur sehr
leicht und die Ermittler finden heraus
die Papiere wurden am Tag des Anschlags
in Zimmer 402 das Hotels Larry weh in
Dortmund gekauft
ich glaube in dem Moment haben wir alle
gedacht Bingo also das ist
ein zu großer Zufall dass ich diese
Person dort aufhält wir haben uns auch
gedacht wieso ist der dort mit seinem
tatsächlichen Namen aufgetreten von
diesem Moment an haben die Ermittler
Sergej wie im Blick einen 28-jährigen
deutschen der in Russland geboren wurde
er soll für den Anschlag verantwortlich
sein doch es fehlen eindeutige Beweise
wir hatten keinerlei Spuren dafür dass
unser jetzt verurteilter Täter denn
tatsächlich diese Bombe hergestellt hat
und in der Hecke vor dem Hotel platziert
hatte werden keinerlei Hinweise darauf
dass wir wissen konnten hat er diese
Bombe auch ausgelöst werden lediglich
Indizien tagelang beschatten sie den
mutmaßlichen Täter wollen herausfinden
ob er Helfer hatte
routine-mäßig sind ja alle Hotelgäste
dann von den Ermittlungsteams
angesprochen worden da waren erstmal
keine Auffälligkeiten hat er dann
wiederholt konfrontiert worden ist
nachdem wir auch schon Erkenntnisse
hatten dann kam so langsam Widersprüche
anhand von Überwachungskameras erstellen
die Ermittler ein Bewegungsprofil am
Abend des Anschlags verhält er sich als
Hotelgast auffällig unauffällig
nach dem Anschlag selbst ist
der Beschuldigte in die Lobby gegangen
nachdem der Beschuldigte kurz draußen
die Lage erhoben hat ist er dann ins
Hotel gegangen ins Restaurant hat sich
dort ein Steak bestellt und hat nachher
noch einen Termin im Wellnessbereich des
Hotels wahrgenommen dort entfernt eine
Masseurin eine Zecke aus seinem
Oberschenkel eine weitere Zecke entfernt
der selber mit einer Pinzette aus der
Schulter die Spurensicherung findet
später heraus dass auch die Stelle im
Wald an der der Brand gelegt wurde vor
der Zecken ist die Ermittler verschaffen
sich mit diesen Luftaufnahmen aus einem
Polizeihubschrauber einen Überblick über
den Tatort stellen die Szene mit einem
fast baugleichen weißen Bus nach sie
wollen herausfinden von wo der Täter die
sprengensätze gezündet haben könnte da
war das Hotelzimmer auch eine
Möglichkeit
aber ich konnte mir damals nicht
vorstellen dass man sich als Täter dort
eingemietet hätte das hat mich später
auch verw undert dass der Täter diesen
Weg gegangen ist
Serge wie hatte sich Zimmer 42 mit Blick
auf den Parkplatz ausdrücklich gewünscht
als die Ermittler das Zimmer betreten
machen Sie diese Fotos so hat es sehr
Gewebe vor seiner Abreise hinterlassen
10 Tage nach dem Anschlag greift die
Polizei in seiner Heimat Rottenburg am
Neckar zu
deine Eltern konnten sich das gar nicht
vorstellen
er hat auch zunächst erstmal sehr
überrascht bei der Durchsuchung finden
die Ermittler Notizblöcke auf denen er
seine Pläne und verschiedene
tatvarianten aufschrieb auf seinem
Computer entdecken sich Hinweise darauf
dass er nach anderen möglichen Zielen
suchte die Eurotunnel AG und mehrere
börsennotierte Bergbahnen
wer ist dieser Mann der diesen perfiden
Plan in die Tat umsetzen wollte sage wie
kommt im Alter von 13 Jahren mit der
Familie aus Russland nach Freudenstadt
im Schwarzwald besuchte auch die
Hauptschule danach Bundeswehr er macht
eine Ausbildung zum Kfz-Mechatroniker
und wird 2015 auf der Berufsschule
Jahrgangs beste dann arbeitet er als
Kesselwärter in einem Heizkraftwerk
das war für mich schon gleich erkennbar
es muss also hier jemand gewesen sein
der auch durchaus eine technische
Begabung hat oder das ganze in der
entsprechenden Art und Weise
hinzubekommen als nach den Anschlägen
von Paris im November 2015 die Börsen
einbrechen da kommt Serge wie die Idee
sagt er später im Prozess er sammelt
Informationen über Borussia Dortmund
über den Bus über das Hotel und
informiert sich ein Jahr später im
Internet darüber wie man Bomben baut
danach hat er bereits im Oktober
angefangen sich entsprechende
Komponenten
zu kaufen zu beschaffen die insbesondere
für eine funkauslösung einer selbst
hergestellten Bombe genutzt werden
können
er hat dann Zeichnungen angefertigt wie
seine Bombe aussehen könnte schon einen
Monat vor der Tat mietet er sich im
larivet ein der BVB spielt gegen Benfica
Lissabon sage wie will vor Ort mehr über
die Abläufe am Mannschaftshotel Wissen
vier Wochen später kommt er wieder um
die Bomben zu zünden
im Dezember 2017 beginnt der Prozess
Sergey ist angeklagt wegen versuchten
Mordes in 29 Fällen außerdem wegen
Herbeiführen einer Sprengstoff Explosion
und gefährlicher Körperverletzungen zwei
Fällen das motivier
die Spieler sagen als Zeugen aus und
schildern was sie erlebt haben kein
leichter Gang Nuri Sahin schildert den
Schrecken in einem britischen
fußballblock
in wenigen Sekunden dachte ich über mein
ganzes Leben nach ich dachte an sterben
und als überleben und an meine Familie
ich sah meinen Sohn meine Tochter und
meine Frau ich konnte fühlen dass sie
bei mir waren
viele der Spieler bekamen Hilfe von
Psychologen niemand will öffentlich über
das Geschehen sprechen Rudolf scheuchel
kann das verstehen mein Mitgefühl in dem
Sinne gilt immer der Mannschaft die da
drinnen sitzen ist also was bin ich bin
der der draufkommen ist also der der das
gesehen hat aber die Mannschaft die war
da drinnen und das muss man sich
vorstellen am Ende ist die Beweislast
erdrückend für die Ermittler eine Erfolg
in diesem außergewöhnlichen Kriminalfall
wenn mich vorher jemand gefragt hätte ob
ich einen entsprechenden Anschlag
bei dem viele Menschen leben gefährdet
sind aus reinem Gewinnstreben für
Möglichkeiten hätte hätte ich gesagt das
wird nie passieren insofern ist das in
der Bewertung herausragenden Anschlag
gewesen obwohl Sergej wie im Prozess
immer wieder beteuer der habe niemanden
verletzen wollen folgt das Gericht der
Staatsanwaltschaft sehr gewe muss für
den Anschlag auf die Mannschaft von
Borussia Dortmund 14 Jahre ins Gefängnis